I'm just about to embark on a five day room renovation
but before I do that I'm just gonna quickly
embark on a boat called the Ranui
I don't get to go out with my husband
without the company of our three mutineers
very often and when we do get to go out
it's usually not to do shit this cold
so quick backstory but those guys that you can see hopping on the boat
are the one and only Australian
Brother sister duo Angus and Julia Stone
and they're pretty fkn iconic if you ask me
and pretty much everyone I know
seriously though
these guys are right up there with my
favourite artists of all time
anyway next month their new record Cape Forestier drops and to celebrate
we're being treated to an intimate concert on a boat
and I can't believe I just got to say that sentence out loud
🎶🎶🎶
And then we got to meet them
And they were so nice
And it turns out Julia loved cleaning as much as I do
which made me literally forget my own name
and I wish I was joking but no
I'm just awkward like that